ein weltraumbahnhof vom meer aus das war
jahrelang das geschäftsmodell des
schweizerischen raumfahrtunternehmen sea
launch doch dann gab es probleme jetzt
wird die odyssee starter plattform aber
über den pazifik nach russland gebracht
könnte es also bald wieder raketen vom
äquator aus ins all schießen klicks um
science fiction die spannen des heims
videos abonniert den kanal und aktiviert
die glocke nur dann und nur dann
verpasst dem nichts los geht's herzlich
willkommen das schweizerische
raumfahrtunternehmen sea launch hatte
eine art weltraum bahnhof auf dem wasser
am start im zeitraum zwischen 1999 und
2014 wurden hier von einer am äquator
schwimmenden plattform satelliten in
besonders hohe umlaufbahn gebracht
der name des projekts ziellos in der
fachsprache ist auch von geo transfer
orbit die rede benötigt werden solche
satelliten die quasi fest über einem
bestimmten punkt der erde stehen vor
allem für die telekommunikation gps
fernsehübertragung und auch das autonome
fahren auf der straße ist ohne sie nicht
möglich tatsächlich stehen sie nicht
fest an einem punkt über der erde
sondern kreisen synchron mit der
erdrotation und genau deswegen die sehr
krasse höhe von 36.000 kilometern
gemessen von der erdoberfläche das muss
man sich mal vorstellen zum besseren
vergleich die iss befindet sich in einer
höhe von 400 kilometern im prinzip
gestaltete sich der ablauf total easy
eine rakete wurde damals auf die
startplattform odyssee geladen und
beides zusammen wurden zu einer stelle
im pazifik gefahren die rund 2000
kilometer südlich von hawaii liegt die
plattform selbst wurde nicht verankert
blieb dank ihres antriebs aber auf einer
konstanten position bevor dann der start
erfolgte wurde die plattform abgesenkt
und die rakete aufgerichtet dann der
start und zwar ferngesteuert so konnte
gewährleistet werden dass die schiffe
genug zeit hatten sich davonzumachen der
standpunkt ist jedenfalls ideal denn bei
einem staat der in der nähe des äquators
stattfindet und bei dem die
entsprechende umlaufbahn angepeilt wird
kann sogar treibstoff gespart werden
denn hier wird die erdrotation der erde
ideal genutzt um geschwindigkeit
aufzunehmen die odyssey kann also im
pazifik vom breitengrad 0 eingesetzt
werden hier sind bei demselben
energieeinsatz höhere nutzlasten möglich
dreimal
das ganze allerdings ganz und gar nicht
30 mal aber perfekt dann kam der ukraine
krieg und damit auch politische probleme
auch in der weltraumindustrie wurden
russische und ukrainische kooperationen
gestoppt und damit ging es auch für die
seals zu ende denn die entscheidende
trägerrakete war ein produkt einer
ukrainisch russischen kooperation sea
launch stellte den weltraumbahnhof auf
dem meer ein hinzu kam außerdem dass
sich zu wenige kunden für den weltraum
dienstleister interessierten da der
staat vom meer aus als zu risikoreich
eingeschätzt wurde die schiffe wurden
also eingemottet vor vier jahren 2016
kamen dann die russische s7 group die
vor allem für ihre fluggesellschaft
bekannt ist das luftfahrt unternehmen
kaufte sea lounge für 150 millionen us
dollar neben dem namen sea lounge ist
darin nicht nur das leid shift ziellos
commander sondern auch die
startplattform odyssee lounge plattform
samt ausrüstung und vorhandenen
installationen enthalten s7 gab damals
an am zielort verfahren und auch an der
technologie bewusst nichts ändern zu
wollen
dazu der ceo des unternehmens wladislaw
iliev im jahr 2016
wir erwarten dass wir innerhalb von 15
jahren 70 starts durchführen können ohne
große investitionen vorzunehmen jetzt
wurden die schiffe jedenfalls wieder zum
leben erweckt und neben auf einem
gigantischen schwerlast schiff mit dem
namen krank goren hua von süd
kalifornien aus kurs in richtung
russland an bord die odyssey
startplattform für trägerraketen an bord
statt wie gewöhnlich risiko auf shop
plattformen im osten russlands erwartet
der s 7 c o wladislaw iliev sehnlichst
darauf nach angaben der russischen
wirtschaftsplattform gilt er als veteran
der geheimen militärischen
weltraumprojekte russlands seine chancen
auf dem markt sehen fachleute allerdings
als eher klein
denn mittlerweile ist ihnen maske mit im
game und eine neue trägerrakete für das
space launch projekt müsste mit der
technik konkurrenzfähig sein der
russische träger sojus 5 soll
möglicherweise in vier jahren 2024
erprobt werden eine weitere
herausforderung die plattform ist nicht
komplett da die bauteile aus den usa und
der ukraine vor dem transport ausgebaut
wurden dazu kommt pro jahr gibt es
lediglich 25 große satelliten starts s7
ist dagegen optimistisch laut wwf wurden
bereits bestellungen für 50
trägerraketen herausgegeben und zudem
auch noch die option
35 weitere neue satelliten für europa
das wusstet ihr nicht anklicken
anschauen und die klugscheißer
abonnieren
neuer extrem coole kanal bei essent 1054
unserem zusammenschluss der coolsten
wissenschafts kanäle also anklicken
anschauen und abonnieren
und ansonsten bis dann bleibt dran